This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's pretty easy to lie with statistics, but it's really easy to lie with statistics when there is a pretty drawing attached. What follows is a story of data visualization and coercion in its centers on a person not particularly well known for either one of these things, the founder of modern nursing Florence Nightingale. And the perfect person to tell this story is Tim Harford, the undercover economist, the author of the Data Detective, and the host of the podcast, Cautionary Tales, which has just started its new season.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。用统计数据撒谎相当容易，但如果配上一张漂亮的图表，用统计数据撒谎就变得非常容易。接下来要讲的是一个关于数据可视化与胁迫的故事，故事的主角并不是以这两者闻名，而是现代护理学的创始人弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔。讲述这个故事的最佳人选是蒂姆·哈福德，他是《卧底经济学家》、《数据侦探》的作者，也是播客《警示故事》的主持人，该播客刚刚开启了新一季。
I could not be more excited, I love this show. I'm so happy it's back. And this episode that we have the honor of premiering is Taylor made for the 99PI crowd. So, without further ado, here's Tim Harvard. The grand barracks at Scootarian Istanbul were said to be the largest in the world when they were completed in the 1820s. By the 1850s, a grim war would turn them into the world's largest hospital. To an experienced eyes, the scutari buildings were magnificent. To ours, in their first state, there were truly whiteed sepulchres, pest houses.
我感到无比兴奋，我热爱这个节目。我很高兴它回归了。我们有幸首播的这一集，简直是为《99%隐形》的听众量身定做的。那么，废话少说，有请蒂姆·哈福德。位于伊斯坦布尔斯库塔里的宏伟军营，在1820年代建成时，据说是世界上最大的军营。到了1850年代，一场残酷的战争将其变成了世界上最大的医院。在经验丰富的人眼中，斯库塔里的建筑群宏伟壮观。但在我们看来，它们最初的状态简直就是粉饰的坟墓，是瘟疫之所。
Those are the words of a British nurse named Florence Nightingale. She sailed out to Istanbul during the Crimean War, a pointless conflict between Russia and an alliance including the British. Nightingale arrived late in 1854, the small team of nurses. Their task was to assist in the care of wounded British soldiers coming back from the battlefront to the hastily converted barracks hospital at Skutari. What did they discover waiting for them? Oh, you gentlemen of England can have little idea from reading the newspapers of the horror
这些话出自一位名叫弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔的英国护士之口。她在克里米亚战争期间航行前往伊斯坦布尔，那是一场俄罗斯与包括英国在内的联盟之间毫无意义的冲突。南丁格尔于1854年底抵达，随行的是一小队护士。她们的任务是协助护理从前线撤回、被匆忙改建为斯库塔里军营医院的受伤英国士兵。她们发现等待她们的是什么？哦，你们这些英国绅士，从报纸上根本无法想象那些垂死和精疲力竭的人在手术时所遭受的恐怖
and misery of operating upon these dying and exhausted men. That this is the kingdom of hell, no one can doubt. Within days of her arrival with fewer than 14 nurses, hundreds of casualties started arriving every day from the fighting in the Crimean Peninsula. These men were bleeding from abdominal wounds. Their faces black with gunpowder and mud, their bodies, crawling
和痛苦。毫无疑问，这就是地狱。在她带着不到14名护士抵达后的几天内，每天都有数百名从克里米亚半岛战场撤回的伤员涌入。这些人腹部伤口流着血，脸上沾满了火药和泥土，身上爬满了
with vermin. After each man died, he'd be stitched up in his own blanket and carried to a mass grave, making space for the next to take his bed. As for the hospital itself, Nightingale was appalled by the conditions and the Shambolic organization. The heating system didn't work, and there was no clean water. The heating system didn't work and there was no clean water. The army supply chain sent the wrong equipment to the wrong place at the wrong time as a matter of routine. And they also seemed to delight in refusing to deal with Nightingale, a woman in a man's world. No mobs, no plates, no wooden trays, no slippers, no shoe brushes, no blacking, no knives
害虫。每死一个人，他就会被缝进自己的毯子里，然后被抬到乱葬岗，为下一个住进他床位的人腾出空间。至于医院本身，南丁格尔对那里的条件和混乱的组织感到震惊。供暖系统无法工作，也没有干净的水。供暖系统无法工作，也没有干净的水。军队的供应链习惯性地把错误的设备送到错误的地方，在错误的时间。他们似乎还以拒绝与南丁格尔打交道为乐，毕竟这是一个男人的世界。没有拖把，没有盘子，没有木托盘，没有拖鞋，没有鞋刷，没有鞋油，没有刀
and forks, no spoons, no scissors for the cutting of men's hair, which is literally alive, no basins, no towering, no chloride of lime. What unfolded that winter was a catastrophe. In January 1855, the British Army in Crimea lost one man in ten to the ravages of diseases such as dysentery and cholera. Many of them died at the hospitals in Skutari. Infectious disease tore the British army to shreds. Back in the UK, the reputation of the generals and politicians was also in tatters. One figure alone emerged with reputation intact. Florence Nightingale. The leader of the nurses in Istanbul was celebrated as the Lady with the Lamp, a near-religious
和叉子，没有勺子，没有剪头发的剪刀，而那些头发里简直全是活物，没有脸盆，没有毛巾，没有氯化石灰。那个冬天发生的一切是一场灾难。1855年1月，英国军队在克里米亚每十个人中就有一人死于痢疾和霍乱等疾病的蹂躏。他们中的许多人死在了斯库塔里的医院里。传染病将英国军队撕成了碎片。在英国国内，将军和政客们的声誉也已破产。只有一个人声誉完好地脱颖而出。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔。这位伊斯坦布尔护士的领袖被誉为“提灯女神”，一个近乎宗教般的
icon of gentleness and dedication, and the most famous woman in the British Empire, except Queen Victoria herself. There is not one of England's proudest and purest daughters who at this moment stands on so high a pinnacle as Florence's nightingale. The soldiers loved her too. If there is any angels on earth, she is one. What glory to see her delicate form gliding about amongst hundreds of great, rough soldiers and to see the looks of love and gratitude that they cast on her beloved face, it will
温柔与奉献的偶像，也是大英帝国除维多利亚女王本人外最著名的女性。此时此刻，英国最骄傲、最纯洁的女儿中，没有谁能像弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔那样站在如此高的巅峰。士兵们也爱戴她。如果世上有天使，她就是其中之一。看到她纤细的身影在数百名粗犷的士兵中穿梭，看到他们投向她那慈爱面庞的爱与感激的目光，那是何等的荣耀，这会
be a brave man at dare in sultan. I would not give a penny for his chance. In May 1855, with conditions at her hospitals improving, Florence Nightingale sailed to the front in Crimea, where she was moved both by the spectacle and by the devotion of the men. The men as a 39th regiment turned out and gave Florence Nightingale three times three as I rode away. There was nothing empty in that chair. And gave Florence Nightingale three times three as I rode away. There was nothing empty in that chair. Florence Nightingale was becoming a saint, but the battle with disease that had shaped her reputation
让一个勇敢的人胆寒。我才不会给他的机会投一分钱。1855年5月，随着医院条件的改善，弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔航行前往克里米亚前线，她被那里的景象以及士兵们的忠诚所感动。第39团的士兵们列队，在我骑马离开时，向弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔高呼了三次万岁。那把椅子上没有什么空虚的东西。在我骑马离开时，向弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔高呼了三次万岁。那把椅子上没有什么空虚的东西。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔正在成为圣人，但那场塑造了她声誉的与疾病的战斗
was about to take a sudden turn. On the 13th of May, a few days after arriving in Crimea and just a day after her 35th birthday, she collapsed. The rumours quickly spread around the British army. Florence Nightingale was dying. I'm Tim Halford and you're listening to cautionary tales. Even today, it is as a nurse that Florence Nightingale is revered in Britain. 25 years ago, my mother took her last breath in a Nightingale hospice. Nightingale's face adorned British banknotes and the front cover of magazines during the COVID-19 pandemic. All hail the hand-washing queen, and we even named our emergency COVID hospitals
即将发生突变。5月13日，在抵达克里米亚几天后，也就是她35岁生日刚过一天，她倒下了。谣言迅速在英军中传开。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔快不行了。我是蒂姆·哈福德，你正在收听的是《警示故事》。即使在今天，弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔在英国仍被尊为护士的典范。25年前，我的母亲在南丁格尔临终关怀医院咽下了最后一口气。南丁格尔的头像出现在英国钞票上，并在新冠疫情期间登上了杂志封面。向洗手女王致敬，我们甚至将紧急新冠医院命名为
the Nightingale hospitals. Nightingale is the ultimate nursing icon. It's as though she had died the day she collapsed in Crimea in May 1855 at the age of 35. Her mission as a nurse had been accomplished her march to heaven was assured, and there was nothing more to be said, which is strange. Because despite the trauma and the sickness staying with her, Nightingale lived until she was 90 years old. And she didn't bask in her celebrity, nor retire to her country home. She had a much bigger battle to fight. One woman and a hand-picked team of geeks versus the entire military and medical establishment of the country, with hundreds of thousands of lives at stake.
“南丁格尔医院”。南丁格尔是终极的护理偶像。就好像她在1855年5月在克里米亚倒下时，年仅35岁就去世了一样。她作为护士的使命已经完成，她通往天堂的道路已经确定，再没有什么可说的了，这很奇怪。因为尽管创伤和疾病一直伴随着她，南丁格尔却活到了90岁。她并没有沉浸在名声中，也没有退休回到乡间别墅。她还有一场更大的战斗要打。一个女人和一队精挑细选的极客，对抗整个国家的军事和医疗机构，赌注是成千上万人的生命。
That huge fight is what this cautionary tale is about. That and the strangely modern weapon she used. Because Florence Nightingale was not only a nurse, she was also, and I mean this as a most sincere compliment, a total nerd. She became a statistician, the first female fellow of the Royal Statistical Society and an honourable member of the American Statistical Association. She was a master of data visualization. If you wanted to be dismissive and some people do, you'd say she was very good at drawing pretty diagrams.
那场巨大的战斗就是这个警示故事的主题。还有她所使用的那种奇怪的现代武器。因为弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔不仅是一位护士，她还是——我这是最真诚的赞美——一个彻头彻尾的书呆子。她成为了一名统计学家，是皇家统计学会的第一位女性会员，也是美国统计协会的荣誉会员。她是数据可视化的专家。如果你想贬低她——有些人确实这么做——你会说她很擅长画漂亮的图表。
But those pretty diagrams changed the world. This is the story of how to fight for a public health revolution armed with a souped-up pie chart. I don't need to tell you how ubiquitous data visualization is. Everywhere we look, whether we check social media, turn on rolling news, or flip through a newspaper, we see graphs and charts, flashy pictures of data, designed to persuade us of something. They're not just decorations. These graphs push and pull us into taking high stakes decisions.
但那些漂亮的图表改变了世界。这是一个关于如何武装自己，用升级版的饼图去争取公共卫生革命的故事。我不需要告诉你数据可视化有多么普遍。无论我们看向哪里，无论是查看社交媒体、打开滚动新闻，还是翻阅报纸，我们都能看到图表，那些旨在说服我们相信什么的华丽数据图片。它们不仅仅是装饰品。这些图表推动并引导我们做出高风险的决策。
COVID-19 reminded us of just how high the stakes can be. People have lived or died because of the decisions they've made after looking at a chart on Facebook. That's why I wanted to understand what Florence Nightingale did with graphs and how she did it. But the deeper I went into the Florence Nightingale archives, the stranger the story became. And it raises a question, if graphs are so powerful, shouldn't we worry about how that power is used? From the hospital in Skutari, Florence Nightingale had tirelessly lobbied for support and assistance, expertly dealing with the press and her political contacts to get what she needed. And in March 1855, came a turning point, a sanitary commission arrived from Britain with the task of cleaning up the hospitals in Scutari. There was a lot of cleaning to
新冠疫情提醒我们，赌注可以有多高。人们因为在Facebook上看到一张图表后做出的决定而生或死。这就是为什么我想了解弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔用图表做了什么，以及她是如何做到的。但我越深入弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔的档案，故事就变得越奇怪。这引发了一个问题：如果图表如此强大，我们难道不应该担心这种力量是如何被使用的吗？在斯库塔里的医院里，弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔不知疲倦地游说以寻求支持和援助，熟练地与媒体和政治人脉打交道以获得她所需的东西。1855年3月，转折点出现了，一个卫生委员会从英国抵达，任务是清理斯库塔里的医院。有很多清理工作要
do. Over the following weeks, they discovered that the drains leading away from the Baruch Hospital were blocked, effectively meaning that the hospital sat on a cesspool. The main water pipes, supplying part of the hospital, was blocked by a decomposing horse. Two dozen more animal carcasses were found on the hospital site. Prefabricated privies had been built in the central courtyard, but excrement was leaking out of the trench beneath them and into an adjacent water tank. By late March, the army was carrying out the commission's recommendations, clearing and flushing the sewers, cutting air vents in the ceilings, removing rotten wood floors and whitewashing everything.
做。在接下来的几周里，他们发现通往巴鲁克医院的排水沟被堵塞了，实际上意味着医院坐落在一个污水坑上。供应医院部分区域的主水管被一匹腐烂的马堵住了。在医院现场还发现了两打以上的动物尸体。中央庭院里建造了预制厕所，但粪便正从下方的沟渠中渗出，流入邻近的水箱。到3月底，军队正在执行委员会的建议，清理和冲洗下水道，在天花板上开通风口，拆除腐烂的木地板，并粉刷一切。
The sanitary commission is really doing something and has set to work burying dead dogs and whitewashing walls, two prolific causes of fever. The death toll was far lower after the commission had done its work. And before, it was a perfect example of what could be achieved to save lives with simple cleanliness and keeping sewage away from the water supply, a nightingale did not forget the lesson. away from the water supply, a nightingale did not forget the lesson. When Florence nightingale returned from the war, Queen Victoria summoned her for a royal audience.
卫生委员会确实在做实事，并着手掩埋死狗和粉刷墙壁，这是导致发热的两个多产原因。委员会完成工作后的死亡人数远低于之前，这是一个关于通过简单的清洁和将污水与供水系统隔离开来就能挽救生命的完美例子，南丁格尔没有忘记这个教训。将污水与供水系统隔离开来，南丁格尔没有忘记这个教训。当弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔从战争中归来时，维多利亚女王召见了她进行皇家接见。
Ah, Miss Nightingale. Your Majesty? We have heard so much about you. Nightingale didn't think much of Victoria. She is the least self-reliant person I've ever known. But the Queen could be useful to her. Florence Nightingale had returned from the Kingdom of Hell with a mission. She wanted to make sure the awful toll of disease in Skutari never happened again in any British hospital anywhere in the world. So Nightingale persuaded Victoria to support a royal commission investigating the health of the army.
啊，南丁格尔小姐。陛下？我们听说了太多关于你的事。南丁格尔对维多利亚评价不高。她是我所知道的最缺乏独立性的人。但女王对她可能有用。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔带着使命从地狱王国归来。她想确保斯库塔里那种可怕的疾病死亡率永远不会在世界任何地方的任何英国医院再次发生。于是南丁格尔说服维多利亚支持一个调查军队健康的皇家委员会。
As a woman, Nightingale was unable to sit on the commission herself, but she assembled her geek allies and worked behind the scenes to figure out the problem. She turned down Queen Victoria's offer of a sweet at Kensington Palace, there would be far too many visitors. Instead, she took rooms at a low rent London hotel. So what had been the underlying cause of the death toll in the Scutari hospitals. To modernise, the answer is obvious. Disease spreads thanks to poor hygiene, poor ventilation and contaminated water, and the hospitals in Scutari suffered from all three. It was not so obvious to Nightingale.
作为一名女性，南丁格尔无法亲自参加委员会，但她召集了她的极客盟友，并在幕后工作以找出问题所在。她拒绝了维多利亚女王在肯辛顿宫提供套房的提议，那里的访客太多了。相反，她在一家低租金的伦敦酒店租了房间。那么，斯库塔里医院死亡率的根本原因是什么？对现代人来说，答案显而易见。疾病的传播归功于卫生条件差、通风不良和水源污染，而斯库塔里的医院三者皆有。这对南丁格尔来说并不那么明显。
Germ theory didn't exist in the 1850s. Although the science was mysterious, Nightingale was one of a group of Victorian thinkers, who were convinced that one way or another, good sanitation should help. With her ally, the great statistician William Far, she assembled and examined the data. Far and Nightingale became convinced that wherever they looked, premature death went hand in hand with open sewers, bad ventilation, and unclean conditions. It wasn't just about the Crimean War. It was an ongoing public health disaster in barracks, civilian hospitals, and beyond.
细菌理论在1850年代并不存在。尽管科学很神秘，但南丁格尔是维多利亚时代一群坚信无论如何，良好的卫生设施应该会有所帮助的思想家之一。在她的盟友、伟大的统计学家威廉·法尔的帮助下，她收集并检查了数据。法尔和南丁格尔确信，无论他们看向哪里，过早死亡都与露天污水沟、通风不良和不洁条件如影随形。这不仅仅是关于克里米亚战争。这是军营、民用医院及其他地方持续不断的公共卫生灾难。
For pair began to campaign for better public health measures, and here the epic battle was joined. They faced powerful opposition. The government didn't want an embarrassing report about the Crimean War already regarded as a fiasco. The Queen, of course, was an instinctive conservative whose idea of reform was to replace one over promoted bureaucrat with another. And neither the army nor the medical profession cared to take instructions from a woman, not even the angel of scutari, Florence Nightingale. In any case, they believed she was surely wrong. A couple of years after the end of the Crimean War in 1858, the chief medical officer, John Simon,
法尔开始为更好的公共卫生措施进行竞选，史诗般的战斗就在这里打响了。他们面临着强大的反对。政府不想要一份关于克里米亚战争的令人尴尬的报告，因为这场战争已经被视为一场惨败。女王当然是一个本能的保守派，她对改革的想法就是用一个过度提拔的官僚取代另一个。军队和医学界都不愿意接受一个女人的指示，即使是斯库塔里的天使，弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔也不例外。无论如何，他们相信她肯定是错的。克里米亚战争结束后几年，即1858年，首席医疗官约翰·西蒙，
acknowledged that contagious diseases such as cholera and dysentery were... A cause of premature death in every civilized country, but that they were... Practically speaking, unavoidable. These diseases just happened, said John Simon, and yes, they killed people. Deal with it, and don't take any lessons from Florence Nightingale. Nightingale was outraged at the complacency. The deaths from disease in British Army barracks were criminally high. It was just as bad, she said. As it would be to take 1,100 men out
承认霍乱和痢疾等传染病是……每个文明国家过早死亡的原因，但它们……实际上是不可避免的。约翰·西蒙说，这些疾病只是发生了，是的，它们杀死了人。处理它，不要从弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔那里学任何东西。南丁格尔对这种自满感到愤怒。英国陆军军营中因疾病导致的死亡人数高得离谱。她说，这和把1100人带到
upon Salisbury plain and suit them. The same for civilian hospitals, private homes, slums, all over the country, men, women, and children were dying, and self-satisfied men like John Simon insisted that these deaths were, practically speaking, unavoidable. The chief medical officer, the generals and the entire British establishment stood against her. Her geek sidekick, statistician William Far, warned her to be careful. Well, if you do it, you will make yourself enemies.
索尔兹伯里平原并射杀他们一样糟糕。民用医院、私人住宅、贫民窟也是如此，全国各地，男人、女人和孩子都在死去，而像约翰·西蒙这样自以为是的人坚持认为这些死亡实际上是不可避免的。首席医疗官、将军们和整个英国建制派都站在她的对立面。她的极客助手、统计学家威廉·法尔警告她要小心。嗯，如果你这么做，你会树敌的。
After what I've seen, I can fire my own guns. And the 19th century heroine had a 21st century weapon. It was a diagram. It's not an accident that these days we're surrounded by graphs and charts. They're the sweet spots between solid statistical evidence on one hand and shareable gifts and filtered photos on the other. Hard data plus striking images. Scientific evidence backs up what any news editor or social media consultant will tell you. Graphs attract attention and they persuade people.
在我所见之后，我可以开火还击。这位19世纪的女英雄拥有21世纪的武器。那是一张图表。如今我们被图表包围并非偶然。它们是坚实的统计证据与可分享的动图和滤镜照片之间的甜蜜点。硬数据加上引人注目的图像。科学证据支持任何新闻编辑或社交媒体顾问会告诉你的话：图表吸引注意力，它们能说服人们。
Researchers at Tufts Visual Analytics Lab found that people formed an impression of a graphic within 500 milliseconds, just half a second. That's far too brief to understand what the graph is about, but it's not too brief to think what a mess or whoo shiny. We respond to images without conscious thought. Another team of researchers, data scientists at New York University, showed people evidence about practical policy questions. For instance, does a high corporate income tax drive jobs overseas, or does prison work as a deterrent? Sometimes the relevant data was in the form of a table, and sometimes in the form of a
塔夫茨视觉分析实验室的研究人员发现，人们在500毫秒内——仅仅半秒钟——就能对一张图表形成印象。这太短暂了，无法理解图表的内容，但足以让人产生“真乱”或“哇，好闪亮”的想法。我们无需意识思考就能对图像做出反应。另一组研究人员，纽约大学的数据科学家，向人们展示了关于实际政策问题的证据。例如，高企业所得税是否会推动就业流向海外，或者监狱是否能起到威慑作用？有时相关数据以表格形式呈现，有时以
chart. Unless people already had a strong position on the subject, the charts were much more persuasive than the tables. If you saw a chart, you were much more likely to change your view. That seems obvious today. It wasn't obvious in the 1850s. Statisticians were much more likely to present their data in the form of a table, even if the tables sprawled across page after page.
图表形式呈现。除非人们对该主题已有强烈立场，否则图表比表格更有说服力。如果你看到一张图表，你更有可能改变你的观点。这在今天看来显而易见。但在1850年代并非如此。统计学家更有可能以表格形式呈现他们的数据，即使表格跨越了一页又一页。
Beautiful design was thought to be superfluous. Florence Nightingale, not for the first time in her life, begged to differ. She would create a graph so compelling that the British establishment would have to bow in acquiescence. The graph in question is titled, Diagram of the Cause of Mortality in the Army in the East. It was published in 1859, the year after Dr. John Simon declared that death from infectious disease was practically speaking unavoidable.
美丽的图形设计被认为是多余的。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔，这并非她一生中第一次，对此表示不敢苟同。她要创造一张如此令人信服的图表，以至于英国建制派不得不屈服。该图表题为《东方军队死亡原因图》。它出版于1859年，即约翰·西蒙医生宣布传染病死亡实际上不可避免的第二年。
Now, I'm going to try my best to describe this image. I've seen an original printing up close in the Library of the Royal Statistical Society in London. It's amazing. But you can find copies online. The first thing you would see, say if you were showing the graph for 500 milliseconds, is that it consists of two pale blue spirals,
现在，我将尽我所能描述这张图像。我在伦敦皇家统计学会图书馆近距离看过原版印刷品。它太棒了。但你可以在网上找到副本。你看到的第一件事，假设你只看了500毫秒，就是它由两个浅蓝色的螺旋组成，
one larger than the other. Look more closely and you see that each spiral is built of twelve equally angled wedges, like the hours of the clock. Some of the wedges are small, clinging near the centre. Others sprawl out hugely, which is what gives the diagram this sense of spiraling in or out. The Rose diagram is a beautiful image, but describes some horrifying numbers. Each of the wedges represents the deaths in a particular month, and the two circles describe the loss of life over two years from April 1854 to March 1856. 1854, to March 1856. The first circle spirals out like a snail. October is not too grave. November, when Nightingale arrived at the hospital in Scutari, is worse. December is worse still. January and February are awful. Swollen wedges of blue so large that they threaten to bleed
一个比另一个大。仔细看，你会发现每个螺旋都是由十二个等角的楔形组成的，就像时钟上的小时。有些楔形很小，紧贴中心。另一些则向外大幅蔓延，这赋予了图表一种向内或向外螺旋的感觉。玫瑰图是一幅美丽的图像，但描述了一些可怕的数字。每个楔形代表特定月份的死亡人数，两个圆圈描述了从1854年4月到1856年3月两年的生命损失。1854年，到1856年3月。第一个圆圈像蜗牛一样向外螺旋。十月还不算太严重。十一月，当南丁格尔抵达斯库塔里的医院时，情况更糟。十二月更糟。一月和二月简直可怕。肿胀的蓝色楔形如此之大，以至于它们威胁要从
off the edge of the page itself. In the centre of the diagram are tiny black and red wedges of blue so large that they threatened to bleed off the edge of the page itself. In the centre of the diagram are tiny black and red wedges. They indicate a handful of deaths from miscellaneous causes and from wounds. The huge blue wedges show the overwhelming death toll from infectious diseases. No one ever made a decision because of a number. They needed a story. So said Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky, the two psychologists whose collaboration would win Kahneman and Nobel Prize after Tversky's death. And Florence Nightingale's diagram, more than anything, is a story. The first half of that story is a catastrophe, but the second circle continues the narrative in April 1855, just after the Sanctuary Commission arrived
页面边缘溢出。图表中心是微小的黑色和红色楔形。它们表示少量死于杂项原因和伤口的死亡人数。巨大的蓝色楔形显示了传染病造成的压倒性死亡人数。没有人会因为一个数字而做出决定。他们需要一个故事。丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基这样说，这两位心理学家的合作在特沃斯基去世后为卡尼曼赢得了诺贝尔奖。而弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔的图表，最重要的是，是一个故事。那个故事的前半部分是一场灾难，但第二个圆圈延续了叙事，在1855年4月，就在卫生委员会抵达
in Scutari. The change is dramatic. The circle is much smaller, and while the first circle spiraled outward in an ever-worsening death count, the second circle shrinks inward as the casualty is dwindle. It's a tale with two halves. After the catastrophe comes the redemption. In between the two of them, flushing out the Suez, casting away the dead horse, disinfecting the hospital buildings. In 1858, John Simon, the chief medical officer, had declared that death from infectious
斯库塔里之后。变化是戏剧性的。圆圈小得多，虽然第一个圆圈以不断恶化的死亡人数向外螺旋，但第二个圆圈随着伤亡人数的减少而向内收缩。这是一个分为两半的故事。灾难之后是救赎。在两者之间，冲洗下水道，扔掉死马，消毒医院建筑。1858年，首席医疗官约翰·西蒙宣布，死于传染
disease was practically unavoidable. In 1859 Florence Nightingale's graph said, that's a lie. Not only are deaths avoidable, but with simple practical measures, the army had avoided them. Those two pale blue circles delivered a powerful two-part payload. John Simon and his allies felt the force of both barrels. As Nightingale explained to an old friend and influential politician, whenever I am infuriated I revenge myself with a new diagram. The graphs and the Rose diagram in particular were part of a deliberate strategy. In another letter to the same friend, written on Christmas Day 1857, she sketched out a plan to use data visualization for social change. She declared her plan to have her diagrams glazed, framed, and hung on the wall at the
病实际上是不可避免的。1859年，弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔的图表说，那是谎言。不仅死亡是可以避免的，而且通过简单的实际措施，军队已经避免了它们。那两个浅蓝色的圆圈传递了一个强大的两部分有效载荷。约翰·西蒙和他的盟友感受到了双管齐下的力量。正如南丁格尔向一位老朋友和有影响力的政客解释的那样，每当我被激怒时，我就会用一张新图表来报复。这些图表，特别是玫瑰图，是有意策略的一部分。在1857年圣诞节写给同一位朋友的另一封信中，她勾勒了一个利用数据可视化进行社会变革的计划。她宣布了她的计划，要将她的图表上釉、装裱，并挂在
Army Medical Board and ward apartment. This is what they do not know, and did ought to. She added, none but scientific men even look into the appendices of a report. And this is for the vulgar public. Now, who is the vulgar public? Who is to have it? The Queen, Prince Albert, all the crown heads in Europe, with the ambassadors, all ministers of each, all the commanding officers in the army, all the regimental surgeons and medical officers, the chief sanitarians in both houses of parliament, all the newspapers, reviews, and magazines. Nightingale's visual story was impossible to ignore. Opinions started to shift, Parliament passed new laws,
陆军医疗委员会和病房公寓的墙上。这是他们不知道，但应该知道的。她补充说，除了科学人士，没有人会看报告的附录。而这是给庸俗大众看的。那么，谁是庸俗大众？谁应该拥有它？女王、阿尔伯特亲王、欧洲所有的加冕首脑，以及大使们、各国的所有部长、军队的所有指挥官、所有的团外科医生和医疗官员、议会两院的首席卫生学家、所有的报纸、评论和杂志。南丁格尔的视觉故事让人无法忽视。舆论开始转变，议会通过了新法律，
doctors adopted new practices. Nightingale understood earlier than most that a chart has a special power. But I can't just end this cautionary tale there on a happy note, because perhaps charts have a little too much power. Our visual sense is potent, so potent that we even use the phrase I see as a direct substitute for I understand.
医生采用了新做法。南丁格尔比大多数人更早理解图表具有特殊的力量。但我不能就这样在一个快乐的音符上结束这个警示故事，因为也许图表的力量有点太大了。我们的视觉感官很强大，强大到我们甚至使用“我看见”这个短语作为“我理解”的直接替代品。
Seeing can be believing, but seeing can also mean fooling yourself. Edward Tufty, perhaps the most influential graphical guru alive, understands the power of visual explanation as well as anyone, his books include Invisioning Information and Beautiful Evidence. But we can envision misinformation too, and it can be just as beautiful, and we can now share it with a click. In mid-March 2020, as we were just beginning to grasp the enormity of the unfolding pandemic. Eric Fagelding, an epidemiologist with a large following and a quick fire style, fired off a graph from the Centers for Disease Control with a warning, Newsflash for young people.
眼见为实，但眼见也可能意味着自欺欺人。爱德华·塔夫特，也许是当今最有影响力的图形大师，像任何人一样理解视觉解释的力量，他的书包括《设想信息》和《美丽的证据》。但我们也可以设想错误信息，而且它可能同样美丽，我们现在可以点击一下就分享它。2020年3月中旬，当我们刚刚开始理解正在展开的疫情的严重性时，埃里克·法格尔丁，一位拥有大量追随者和快节奏风格的流行病学家，从疾病控制中心发出了一张图表，并附带警告：给年轻人的新闻快报。
You are not invincible. You're just as likely to be hospitalized as older generations. Even CDC says so. But the CDC's graph didn't show that at all. It showed that vastly more over 45s than under 45s were in hospital. But it was easy to misunderstand the graph if you didn't look closely at the tiny, tiny labels on the axes. And who looks at the tiny, tiny labels, eh? And so an epidemiologist who should have known better but was just a little too eager to tweet unwittingly spread
你们不是不可战胜的。你们住院的可能性和老一代人一样大。连疾控中心都这么说。但疾控中心的图表根本没有显示这一点。它显示45岁以上住院的人数远多于45岁以下。但如果你不仔细看轴上微小的标签，很容易误解这张图表。谁会看那些微小的标签呢，对吧？于是，一位本应更了解情况但却太急于发推特的流行病学家，无意中向他的30万粉丝传播了
misinformation to his 300,000 followers. It gets worse. A few days later, the right-wing it and Coulter tweeted a pair of graphs and the comment, for people under 60 coronavirus is less dangerous than the seasonal flu. But the graphs showed the precise opposite of Coulter's claim. Covid-19 was about 8 times as deadly as flu for people in their 50s and 5 times as deadly for people in their 30s and 40s. It's like tweeting a picture of a cow next to a cat with a title, cows are smaller than cats. Observed, except, Coltas' up-is-down message was retweeted more than 11,000 times. Within a few hours of each other, two Twitter influencers, one overplaying the risk of
错误信息。情况更糟。几天后，右翼的安·库尔特发推文说了一对图表，并评论道：对于60岁以下的人来说，冠状病毒比季节性流感危险性更小。但图表显示的结果与库尔特的说法恰恰相反。对于50多岁的人来说，新冠病毒的致命性大约是流感的8倍，对于30多岁和40多岁的人来说是5倍。这就像发一张奶牛和猫的照片，标题是“奶牛比猫小”。荒谬，除了库尔特这种“上下颠倒”的信息被转发了超过11000次。在几个小时内，两位推特网红，一个夸大
COVID and the other underplaying it, were tweeting graphs that they hadn't understood. It didn't seem to stop those tweets going viral. All too many people seem to think any claim with a graph attached must be true. People make life-changing decisions because of graphical misinformation like this, quitting a job in fear, but in fact the risk is low, or recklessly exposing others to deadly risk because they've been told the virus is fake news. It turns out that data visualization is a dual-use technology. It can be a tool or a weapon. Florence Nightingale was perhaps the first person in history to grasp that a well-designed
新冠的风险，另一个淡化它，都在发他们自己都没看懂的图表。这似乎并没有阻止那些推文疯传。太多人似乎认为任何附带图表的声明都一定是真的。人们因为这样的图形错误信息而做出改变生活的决定：因为恐惧而辞职，但实际上风险很低；或者因为被告知病毒是假新闻而鲁莽地将他人置于致命风险之中。事实证明，数据可视化是一种双重用途的技术。它可以是工具，也可以是武器。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔也许是历史上第一个意识到精心设计的
graph based on solid data can be remarkably persuasive. Experience has taught us the unfortunate lesson that a badly designed graph or a graph based on flimsy data, while they can be remarkably persuasive too. More of Tim Harford's cautionary tales are 99% invisible after this. There is a strange twist in this story, because while Florence Nightingale is revered by many graphic designers, many others despise her rose diagram. Edward Tufty, the influential author of Beautiful Evidence, criticised the graph on his website.
基于可靠数据的图表可以非常具有说服力的人。经验教训告诉我们一个不幸的事实：设计糟糕的图表或基于脆弱数据的图表，虽然它们也可以非常具有说服力。更多蒂姆·哈福德的《警示故事》将在《99%隐形》之后播出。这个故事有一个奇怪的转折，因为虽然弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔受到许多图形设计师的崇拜，但许多其他人却鄙视她的玫瑰图。爱德华·塔夫特，有影响力的《美丽的证据》的作者，在他的网站上批评了这张图表。
The inherent problem is the difficulty of making good comparisons across the wedges. In general for such small datasets, tables will outperform graphics. The diagram is unclear, and since there aren't that many numbers to portray, Nightingale should simply have used a table. Nightingale's statistical contemporaries would have agreed, but I've seen the data in Nightingale's graph presented as a table, and the first thing that sprang to mind was Nightingale's own comment to her friend in that Christmas Day letter of 1857. In this form printed tables and all in double columns, I do not think anyone will read it. Remember to whom she sent this earth-shaking diagram?
固有的问题是难以在楔形之间进行良好的比较。通常对于这样的小数据集，表格的表现会优于图形。该图表不清晰，而且由于没有那么多数字需要描绘，南丁格尔应该简单地使用表格。南丁格尔的统计学同时代人也会同意，但我看过南丁格尔图表中的数据以表格形式呈现，脑海中浮现的第一件事就是南丁格尔在1857年圣诞节那封信中对她朋友的评论。以这种形式，打印的表格和所有双栏，我不认为有人会读它。记得她把这张震撼世界的图表发给了谁吗？
The Queen, Prince Albert, all the crown heads in Europe, all the newspapers, reviews and magazines. Tables can be clearer, but tables don't grab your attention in 500 milliseconds, and kings and queens and ministers and newspaper editors are busy, as Nightingale rather acedly noted when she sent her report to Queen Victoria. She may look at it because it has pictures. Fine, the message demands a graph, but surely there's a better, clearer graph conveying the same message.
女王、阿尔伯特亲王、欧洲所有的加冕首脑、所有的报纸、评论和杂志。表格可以更清晰，但表格不会在500毫秒内抓住你的注意力，而国王、女王、部长和报纸编辑都很忙，正如南丁格尔在将报告发给维多利亚女王时相当尖刻地指出的那样。她可能会看它，因为它有图片。好吧，信息需要一张图表，但肯定有更好、更清晰的图表传达同样的信息。
Certainly, that's what Edward Tufty's followers believe in the comments on his website. Is it wrong that I'm erased by a graphic? Good design is not drawing pretty pictures and shoe-horning the facts in later. These knighting-gale roses are just a type of pie chart and contain all the disadvantages of pie charts. Wow, the disadvantages of pie charts. Wow, that's quite a burn. The charts are difficult to read. I would have thought that a stacked bar chart on a time scale would have been a better choice.
当然，这就是爱德华·塔夫特的追随者在评论区所相信的。我被一张图表所吸引是错的吗？好的设计不是画漂亮的图片，然后把事实硬塞进去。这些南丁格尔玫瑰图只是一种饼图，包含了饼图的所有缺点。哇，饼图的缺点。哇，那真是相当刻薄。图表很难阅读。我本以为时间轴上的堆叠条形图会是一个更好的选择。
Good idea. Let's try a bar chart. And here's where the plot thickens. Because when I first saw the data presented as a bar chart, my jaw dropped. It is absolutely clear and easy to read, and that's the problem. When you see the data presented in a clear, modern format, you start to realise something. Maybe Florence Nightingale wasn't quite as saintly as everyone thought. Florence Nightingale's diagram divides the data into two halves. That's not an accident. The colour diagram number one shows the sanitary state of the army before the arrival of the sanitary commission.
好主意。让我们试试条形图。这就是情节变得复杂的地方。因为当我第一次看到以条形图呈现的数据时，我的下巴惊掉了。它绝对清晰易读，而这正是问题所在。当你看到以清晰、现代的格式呈现的数据时，你开始意识到一些事情。也许弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔并不像每个人认为的那样圣洁。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔的图表将数据分为两半。那并非偶然。彩色图表一显示了卫生委员会到达前军队的卫生状况。
The colour diagram number two shows what it became after that event. Catastrophe before, recovery after. And as I've mentioned, Nightingale was aiming not at a post-mortem of the Crimean War, but at the far bigger goal of public health reform. Similar diagrams might be constructed for towns in their unimproved and improved state. Nature is the same everywhere, and never permits her laws to be disregarded with impunity. The argument is powerful, and the conclusion is correct. Life expectancy strikingly
彩色图表二显示了该事件之后的情况。之前是灾难，之后是恢复。正如我提到的，南丁格尔的目标不是克里米亚战争的尸检，而是公共卫生改革这个更大的目标。类似的图表可以为处于未改善和改善状态的城镇构建。自然在任何地方都是一样的，从不允许她的法律被无视而不受惩罚。这个论点很有力，结论也是正确的。预期寿命在19世纪下半叶显著
improved in the second half of the 19th century, and the sanitary and revolution, cleaner water, cleaner homes, cleaner air, deserves much of the credit. But that's why it's so shocking to see the data from the Rose diagram re-plotted as a bar chart. When you do that, the stark, before and after story is lost. By the time the Sanitary Commission arrived in March, flushing horses out of the water supply and carrying away tons of human excrement, deaths had already been falling sharply for a couple of months. Mark Bostridge, the author of an award-winning biography of Nightingale, argues that deaths were falling because new arrivals were in better health. In part, thanks to the better weather.
提高，卫生革命、更清洁的水、更清洁的家园、更清洁的空气，功不可没。但这就是为什么看到玫瑰图的数据被重新绘制成条形图时如此令人震惊。当你这样做时，鲜明的“之前和之后”的故事就消失了。到3月份卫生委员会到达，将马匹从供水系统中冲走并运走数吨人类排泄物时，死亡人数已经连续几个月急剧下降。马克·博斯特里奇，南丁格尔获奖传记的作者，认为死亡人数下降是因为新抵达的人健康状况更好。部分归功于更好的天气。
They were less numerous, so the hospital was less overcrowded, and with fewer soldiers in the hospital, of course, there'd be fewer deaths. There's no doubt that better sanitation works, but an unvarnished presentation of Nightingale's data would have suggested that the truth was complicated, and complicated, wasn't going to serve her purposes. So she created her rose diagram. The same data, artfully presented, tells a very different story. There's a famous remark in a letter that passed between Nightingale and her ally, the great statistician, William Far. You complained that your report would be dry. The dry are the better. Statistics should
他们人数较少，所以医院没那么拥挤，而且医院里的士兵少了，当然死亡人数也会减少。毫无疑问，更好的卫生设施有效，但对南丁格尔数据的未经修饰的呈现会表明真相是复杂的，而“复杂”并不能服务于她的目的。所以她创造了她的玫瑰图。同样的数据，巧妙地呈现，讲述了一个非常不同的故事。在南丁格尔和她的盟友、伟大的统计学家威廉·法尔之间的一封信中有一句名言。你抱怨你的报告会很枯燥。越枯燥越好。统计数据应该
be the driest of all reading. Several biographers have reported that remark as being written by Far to Nightingale. That makes sense. The Fusty, middle-aged statistician was advising the fiery, younger advocate to rein in her righteous campaigning influences and thankfully she ignored him. Except the biographers are wrong. Confused, perhaps, by the fact that the surviving draft of this letter was dictated to an assistant and unsigned, but while researching my new book, the data detective, I tracked the letter down, and it wasn't from far to nightingale, it was the other way around. You complain that your report would be dry. The dry at the better. Statistics should
是所有阅读中最枯燥的。几位传记作者报道说那句话是法尔写给南丁格尔的。这说得通。古板的中年统计学家在建议火热的年轻倡导者收敛她正义的竞选影响，谢天谢地她没理他。除了传记作者错了。也许是因为这封信的现存草稿是口述给助手且未签名的，但在研究我的新书《数据侦探》时，我追踪了这封信，它不是从法尔写给南丁格尔的，而是反过来的。你抱怨你的报告会很枯燥。越枯燥越好。统计数据应该
be the driest of all reading. She was telling him to play it straight and avoid editorialising. Solid evidence first, she said, and worry about the sales pitch later. Good advice for any scientist. In the same letter, she added, We want facts. Fact-a-fact-a-fact-a is the motto which ought to stand at the head of all statistical work. It's puzzling. How could she produce the famous rose diagram, an artfully constructed piece of statistical storytelling, while being the same person who told William Fart to keep it dusty dry? My guess is that she was far too clever to build an argument on shaky foundations. The more spectacular the statistical acrobatics, the more solid the numbers needed to be. But it's just a guess. I don't
是所有阅读中最枯燥的。她在告诉他要直截了当，避免发表社论。她说，先有坚实的证据，然后再担心推销。这对任何科学家来说都是好建议。在同一封信中，她补充道：我们需要事实。事实、事实、事实是所有统计工作之首应有的座右铭。这很令人困惑。她怎么能制作出著名的玫瑰图，一件巧妙构建的统计叙事作品，同时又是那个告诉威廉·法尔保持枯燥的人？我的猜测是，她太聪明了，不会在摇摇欲坠的基础上建立论点。统计杂技越壮观，数字就越需要坚实。但这只是猜测。我不知道。
know. I don't even know if this cautionary tale has a happy ending. If the end justifies the means, I suppose it does, because she won. Nightingale and her allies saved countless lives, transforming the health of Victorian Britain and arguably of the world. Most of Nightingale's campaigning took place while she was confined to her bedroom by the long illness she had acquired in Crimea, and she emerged. Triumphant. Jerm theory had vindicated her focus on hygiene and public health. Her sanitary and reforms had been broadly implemented.
我甚至不知道这个警示故事是否有圆满的结局。如果目的证明手段是正当的，我想是的，因为她赢了。南丁格尔和她的盟友挽救了无数生命，改变了维多利亚时代英国乃至整个世界的健康状况。南丁格尔的大部分竞选活动是在她因在克里米亚患上的长期疾病而局限于卧室时进行的，她脱颖而出。胜利了。细菌理论证明了她对卫生和公共卫生的关注。她的卫生改革得到了广泛实施。
The everyday health of ordinary citizens had been transformed. Even Dr. John Simon, it seems, had quietly recognized his mistake. He published a collection of his essays, and without acknowledging the change, he altered the line that said that deaths from disease were, practically speaking, unavoidable. Instead saying they were, in some degree, unavoidable. From saying, there's nothing we can do to save lives. John Simon had softly sidestept into saying, well, we can't save everyone. Florence Nightingale and her rose diagram had defeated him. But let's be careful. Because it seems that if you give us 500 milliseconds alone with a pretty graph, we're all suckers. The first data visualization to change the world did so by exploiting our visual gullibility.
普通公民的日常健康状况得到了改变。甚至约翰·西蒙医生似乎也悄悄承认了他的错误。他出版了一本论文集，在没有承认改变的情况下，他修改了那行说疾病死亡实际上是不可避免的话。改为说它们在某种程度上是不可避免的。从说“我们无能为力挽救生命”，约翰·西蒙轻轻地侧身变成了说“好吧，我们不能挽救所有人”。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔和她的玫瑰图击败了他。但我们要小心。因为似乎如果你给我们500毫秒的时间单独面对一张漂亮的图表，我们都是傻瓜。第一张改变世界的数据可视化是通过利用我们的视觉轻信而做到的。
Florence Nightingale's beautiful graphic proved a powerful weapon. And now it's a weapon that anyone with any motive can pick up and use. Key sources for this episode include Mark Bostritch's biography and Lin McDonnell's collected works of Florence Nightingale, Hugh Small's presentation to the Royal Statistical Society, and my own book, The Data Detective, Ten Easy Rules to Make Sense of Statistics. For a full list of references, see TimHalford.com. Corsion Retails is written by me, Tim Halfafard with Andrew Wright, it's produced by Ryan
弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔美丽的图形证明了一种强大的武器。现在，这是一个任何有动机的人都可以拿起并使用的武器。本集的主要来源包括马克·博斯特里奇的传记和林·麦克唐纳收集的弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔作品、休·斯莫尔向皇家统计学会的演讲，以及我自己的书《数据侦探：理解统计数据的十条简单规则》。如需完整参考列表，请访问TimHalford.com。《警示故事》由我蒂姆·哈福德与安德鲁·赖特共同撰写，由瑞安制作。
Dilly and Marilyn Rust. The sound design and original music is the work of Pascal Weiss. Julia Barton edited the scripts. Starring in this series of Corsion retails are Helen Abotten Carter and Jeffrey Wright, alongside Nazar Eldorazi, Ed Gohan, Melanie Guthridge, Rachel Hanshaw, Kobyna Holdbrook Smith, Greg Lockett, Masey M. Rowe, and Rufus Wright. This show wouldn't have been possible without the work of Mia LeBell, Jacob Weisberg, Heather Fein, John Schnarrs, Carly McLeory, Eric Sandler, Emily Rostick,
Dilly和Marilyn Rust。声音设计和原创音乐由Pascal Weiss制作。Julia Barton负责剧本编辑。本系列Corsion零售故事由Helen Abotten Carter和Jeffrey Wright主演，其他演员包括Nazar Eldorazi、Ed Gohan、Melanie Guthridge、Rachel Hanshaw、Kobyna Holdbrook Smith、Greg Lockett、Masey M. Rowe和Rufus Wright。没有Mia LeBell、Jacob Weisberg、Heather Fein、John Schnarrs、Carly McLeory、Eric Sandler和Emily Rostick的工作，这个节目就不可能实现。
Maggie Taylor, Anneela LeCarn and Maya Canig. Cautionary Tales is a production of Pushkin Industries. If you like the show, please remember to rate, share and review. The new season of cautionary tales is out now. Go subscribe and listen. I love the show. I'm so happy it's back. And then once you subscribe, go buy all of Tim Hartford's books because they're fantastic. The latest one is called The Data Detective. rules to make sense of statistics.
Maggie Taylor、Anneela LeCarn和Maya Canig。《警世故事》是Pushkin Industries的作品。如果您喜欢这个节目，请记得评分、分享和评论。《警世故事》新一季现已推出。快去订阅收听吧。我非常喜欢这个节目，很高兴它回归了。订阅之后，去买Tim Hartford的所有书吧，因为它们太棒了。最新的一本叫《数据侦探：理解统计数据的规则》。
99% of visible is a product of 91.7K LW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row and beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We remember a radio topia from PRX a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find mall at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 9.9.pi org or on Instagram and read it to that our home for beautiful nerds is 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From P-R-X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99% Invisible是旧金山91.7K LW的产品，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。我们是来自PRX的Radiotopia的一员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm上可以找到所有节目。您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99pi.org，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注我们。我们为美丽的极客们提供的家园是99pi.org。Radiotopia。来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。